>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington,DC.
>> Juan Felipe Herera: Hello,
I am Juan Felipe Ferraro,
the US Poet Laureate of the
United States and I am here
with Nathan Dorn, Curator of
the Law Library of Congress.
And this is a special segment for El
Jardin, part of the Casa de Colores,
and Nathan has laid out a number
of very interesting books.
What do we have Nathan?
>> Nathan Dorn: Well, what I
tried to do is I tried to bring
out some samples from the Law
Library's Hispanic law collection
and I wanted to bring them
out because they begin to hint
at the richness and depth of
our collection on this subject.
Before I show you the items, I want
to tell you about the beginning
of our Hispanic law collection.
The Law Library has been collecting
books from foreign jurisdictions
from its very origins in the
beginning of the nineteenth century.
But the main collecting
activities of legal literature
from foreign jurisdictions didn't
really get underway until the middle
of the nineteenth century.
And the most important event
for that beginning was
the Mexican American War.
The Mexican American War was a war
that took place between
1846 and 1848.
It was a contest especially
over land and at the close
of the war the United States found
itself in possession of New Mexico,
Arizona, California and basically
an entire new continent to the west
of its previous holdings
in North America.
So Congress realizing that that
land until recently had been
under jurisdictions whose
historical roots lie
in the Spanish Empire
realized they would need
to understand how property
was regulated,
how contracts were regulated,
how the cities were regulated,
and how the people
understood themselves.
So they required the Law Library
of Congress to acquire law books
from those jurisdictions especially
Spain, the Spanish Empire,
and Mexico until that date.
So that was in 1848.
They didn't actually allocate
funds until 1854 but at
that point the Library went out on
a spending...on a shopping spree
and eventually after several decades
of collecting, we have many, many,
many volumes that represent
the entire history of,
the entire early print
history of Hispanic law
about 1200 volumes until 1801.
And these here represent some
of the really priceless
treasures in that collection.
>> Herrera: Beautiful and
what do we have up here?
>> Dorn: Okay...the beginning
of Hispanic law is shrouded
somewhat in antiquity.
We had at the fall of the Roman
Empire, a small code of Roman law.
That was the only code of
Roman law that survived
in unbroken tradition
throughout the middle ages.
And that was the Breviary of Alaric,
which was a bit of Roman law,
really roman not barbarian
but it was in the hands
of a Germanic tribe,
eventually the Visigothic Tribe
and over centuries it
was adapted and changed
and it becomes the basic,
one of the primary documents
of Hispanic Law, the
Visigothic Code.
It's published, is printed, for
the first time very late 1550.
We have it here in a 1579 edition.
Already in this edition in
Paris of Sebastian Nevellis,
the Visigothic Code was very much an
active law code throughout medieval
Spain and it was eventually folded
into a subsequent publication known
as the Fuero juzgo which remained
living Spanish law throughout
history of the Spanish
Empire in North America.
>> Herrera: You know, now that
you mention the Visigothic Code,
what items or ideas come
from, were adapted or adopted
from the Visigothic Code into
this particular book right here?
>> Dorn: So this here is an
imprint of the Visigothic Code.
You can have a look inside.
>> Herrera: It's a total imprint...
>> Dorn: It is a total imprint
of the Visigothic Code itself.
And it contains all the
provisions of that code
and it's a fully functioning code
with family law and inheritance law
and other things that
will help a kingdom run.
Now, in Medieval Spain
in the 13th century,
King Alfonso the 10th required
that a new publication of law come
out that would incorporate not
just the Roman law inheritance
but also the customary law of the
kingdom of Spain that was coming
up through the Middle Ages.
Now all the jurisdictions of Europe
would eventually codify their
customary law codes and this volume
represents that codification,
the 13th century codification
of Spanish law
into what's called
the Siete Partidas.
>> Herrera: Las Siete Partidas.
>> Dorn: Siete Partidas.
Now it's very important,
crucially important publication
in early Spanish law because while
it's a 13th century document,
it really became the basis of
Spanish law for quite a long time
with some competition from the
Fuero juzgo which is the descendent
of this, the Visigothic code.
The Siete Partidas was
imported to the Americas
when the Spanish arrived and
remained an integral part
of the legal material, the
basic legal references,
of anybody who is working in the
law throughout the Spanish speaking
Americas for hundreds of years.
Now to get the point across,
so widespread was the use
of the Siete Partidas, I will talk
about this edition in a moment,
that even after parts of
America that were once
under Spanish influence
came to be states,
here you have an 1820
volume from Louisiana.
It's called Las Siete Partidas,
those laws of Las Siete Partidas
which are still in force
in the State of Louisiana.
>> Herrera: So that's what we
were talking about a while ago
and I was talking with Nathan and
Nathan explained Las Siete Partidas
and the Visigothic Code
and then Louisiana.
Why is it, how is it, that we get
such laws can continue all
the way to the present?
What's going on, what's the power of
these words, or what are the codes
that are so important, so what
makes them so long lasting?
>> Dorn: Generally speaking
law is very conservative
and the reason it's very
conservative is because people's,
people's property and all their
assets and all the arrangements
by which they live their lives are
tied up in the particular provisions
that exist already on the books.
And so nobody wants you to come in
and totally revolutionize the
legal system that you are sitting
in because then what happens to all
your rights, what happens to all
of your holdings and in no
case, even in the beginning
of Spanish speaking settlement
in North America and then
in Anglo settlement in those same
regions throughout the southwest was
there such a revolution
that everybody simply wanted
to level whatever had been before.
It just didn't happen.
What happened instead
was people wanted
to receive what was already
there to such a degree,
whatever degree necessary,
to preserve property rights
and make sure that
everyone who had something
to lose could protect what they had.
Okay, so...
>> Herrera: That's very good.
>> Dorn: So what we have
here is Las Siete Partidas...
>> Herrera: Las Siete Partidas.
>> Dorn: ...in a 1491
edition from Seville.
>> Herrera: ...from Seville,1491
>> Dorn: ...And so I promised
you a little while ago
that we would have a five
hundred year old book.
>> Herrera: Yes, you did.
>> Dorn: So here's our
five hundred year old book
and it's a very beautiful pristine
copy of that Las Siete Partidas
which is such an important part
of Spanish law in North America.
>> Herrera: Five hundred years old.
>> Dorn: Five hundred plus.
>> Herrera: Five hundred
plus and we go to...
>> Dorn: Number 4.
>> Herrera: Number 4.
>> Dorn: Okay.
>> Herrera: Let's go to number 4.
>> Dorn: Okay, here we are.
So let's skip ahead
in time to Mexico.
This is a really interesting book.
It's widely understood to be
the second law book printed
in the New World.
It's printed at the printing
press of Pedro Ocharte
who is the second printer
operating in Mexico City.
It's printed in 1565 and it's
called the Cedulario de Puga
and it's compiled by a man called
Vasco de Puga who was a judge
in the Audiencia which is
the court of Mexico City.
And what it contains is all those
laws that govern Mexico City
from 1528 to 1565 which is
really the first stretch
of Mexican history.
>> Herrera: Yes it is.
That's a lot of laws right there.
>> Dorn: That's a lot of laws.
Well it's not that many laws.
It's just a little bit more,
really it's just a l ittle bit more
than the ordinances that control the
city, because we're only beginning
to control vast stretches
of America under these laws.
>> Herrera: That's right
and do these laws also apply
to indigenous peoples
of Mesoamerica,
Mexico City at that time?
>> Dorn: Oh yes.
Oh yes. This is the code
that runs the nation state.
So you have an idea that it has
some beautiful illuminated initials.
>> Herrera: They do.
And this is one of the early,
or the first, printing you said?
>> Dorn: This is the first
printing of the Cedulario de Puga,
the official printing 1565.
Okay. But before we leave
Mexico City, let's not forget.
>> Herrera: Oh, we almost forgot!
We almost forgot!
We had this prepared
but we almost forgot.
This is what's very interesting.
You told me that this is a
manual, a marriage manual
and this is what, the
custom, the laws?
These are the laws that
regulate what marriage is
and how marriage can be
maintained and how to define it.
>> Dorn: Correct.
>> Herrera: And more...
>> Dorn: On all points, correct.
Okay, so we haven't
left Mexico City,
in fact we are going
backward in time.
Here we have a book
probably published in 1556,
a few years earlier than the
1565 over here and it's published
by the very first printer
operating in the Americas.
>> Herrera: That was the first
printer that I was thinking about.
>> Dorn: That's Juan Pablos.
That's right.
>> Herrera: What is the
name of the printer?
>> Dorn: Juan Pablos.
>> Herrera: Just plain
ol' Juan Pablos?
>> Dorn: In fact he's Italian
and he adopted a Spanish
version of his name.
>> Herrera: You didn't
tell me that last time.
>> Dorn: Oh no?
Okay so here he is, he is living
in Mexico City all the same.
He's operating his printing press
there from about 1539 until 1561,
which is the time of his death which
is only a few years after this.
This is a very, this is perhaps
the first book length printing
in America.
And so we have this beautiful book.
It's the Speculum Coniugiorum like
you were saying, that's the handbook
of marriage relations
and it's written
by an Augustinian friar
called Alonso de la Vera Cruz.
And Vera Cruz lived from the
beginning of the sixteenth century
until sometime in the 1570s and
I think, and he was remarkable
because he was quite a
philosophical genius.
He studied at the University
of Salamanca
and was already appointed
a lectureship
which is a highly coveted position
before he met some missionaries
returning to Spain from the Americas
who described to him the life there
and what one could do in
service of the church.
And he just fell in love with
the idea and the romance of it
and he went off to America and very
soon he was working among the Aztec
Indians and the Tarascan
Indians as a missionary.
Now this work represents
the culmination of many,
many years of practical,
on the ground experience
converting native peoples
and bringing them into the church.
One of the big issues for converts
is a different kinship structure,
the kinship structure that you have
under the canon law of
the catholic church.
>> Herrera: That's right.
We were talking about that too,
how converting the indigenous
peoples through, by converting,
one person in the family perhaps the
father we can easily then convert
the entire family and here
is the handbook that is going
to guide this new form of marriage
and kinship system, inheritance,
and all those things
that go along with it.
>> Dorn: Correct.
>> Herrera: And so that's
a very powerful book.
>> Dorn: I think so, and
it's not just a law book.
It doesn't just tell you
about the laws of marriage.
It's also a book about...you know
what I'm looking for...I'm looking
for that beautiful diagram.
It's also a book about the
meaning of marriage as a sacrament
and the theological
significance to...
that the marriage has.
And so it's quite a remarkable book.
It even includes a little bit
of the, a little bit of detail
about the life and marriage
customs of the Tarascan Indians.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Dorn: So, here you have
an interesting chart...
>> Herrera: Show it
to them, go ahead.
So here we have a chart.
>> Dorn: So this chart shows the
degrees of family relationship,
the ones, the degrees that
measure how far one must be
in the family tree from another
before the two can marry.
>> Herrera: It's right here.
>> Dorn: According to Canon
Law, you can't be too close,
you must have a certain
number of degrees between you
and this helps you count and any
two family members how many degrees
apart they are.
So this is an interesting chart.
You will find it in a lot of books.
>> Herrera: It kind of
resembles some of those paintings
that I have seen in the colonial
period in Mexico that have kind
of relationships to
the notion of God.
>> Dorn: It sounds mystical.
>> Herrera: Yeah, it does
and so this is kind of a lot
of things going on in here.
But it's good.
I have never seen that,
a diagram like that.
>> Dorn: Oh, okay.
>> Herrera: How about that.
>> Dorn: So we have,
some of the books
in the Law Library were there is
a little bit more of elaboration,
the diagrams are like this but they
branch out in seven directions,
seven degrees in this way, seven
degrees in this way, and the artists
who create those diagrams
take the opportunity
to make them really special.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Dorn: And so that's
something to see sometime.
>> Herrera: Then you have more
colors in there and everything.
>> Dorn: Yeah.
>> Herrera: ...the paint.
>> Dorn: It's quite pretty.
>> Herrera: It's beautiful.
You have to look at
that, it's amazing!
>> Dorn: And so here we are
in colonial Spain and...
>> Herrera: Tell us
about this man here.
>> Dorn: This is a
manuscript created
by a man who's suffered
some kind of insult.
His rights weren't respected,
and the rights that he presumed
that he had as a member
of the aristocracy.
And so what one does if that
happens is one goes to court
to claim your right
according to your privilege.
And so happy was he that
he vindicated his claim...
>> Herrera: So he won the case.
>> Dorn: Won the case...that
he sat down and had somebody,
probably not him, probably
an expert,
produce this beautiful manuscript,
a just beautifully written
manuscript documenting his claims.
>> Herrera: His claims...
>> Dorn: So here's this
beautiful illumination.
>> Herrera: It is and
how old is this book?
>> Dorn: From 1598.
>> Herrera: 1598 and the
case of a noble that wanted
to make sure everybody knew
that he indeed was a noble man
or a member of the aristocracy.
>> Dorn: Juan Gutierrez de Peralta.
>> Herrera: Yeah...Juan
Gutierrez de Peralta.
>> Dorn: We don't want
to forget this.
In our conversation earlier,
our conversation ranged all
over the place, but one of
the things that we spoke
about was the destiny of some
of the Spanish empire's holdings
that would eventually become parts
of the United States of America.
And so I mentioned this item
which is a really special item
in the Law Library's collection.
It's one of a kind, that is to say,
we don't know of another
copy of this item.
It's a printed item so there should
be other copies but we don't know
of another existing copy.
This one is, this is
a batch of ordinances
for Florida created in 1821.
I think some people remember
that Florida became part
of the United States
in part by filibuster.
That is to say Andrew Jackson was
permitted or ordered or permitted
to go across the border from
Georgia into Spanish Florida
to rout the threat of some kind of
incursion by Indians into Georgia.
And what the entire factual
background of that story is a matter
for historians, but certainly
Jackson entered Florida,
put to rout the local Indians
and took control of Florida.
And these ordnances were promulgated
just after that conquest.
Now what you really liked, you
remind me, is Ordnance Number 3.
>> Herrera: Ordinance Number 3.
>> Dorn: Ordinance Number
3 of these ordinances.
>> Herrera: Here it is.
Get ready everybody.
>> Dorn: Alright.
>> Herrera: I was pretty
surprised when you told me
about this and we looked at it.
In effect, Andrew Jackson declared
citizenship rights to all those
at that moment in this
land called Florida.
>> Dorn: That's what happened.
>> Herrera: And in a quick statement
and a written declaration also,
or a verbal statement only?
>> Dorn: Well, he published
some kind of ordinance
as the territorial governor of
the federal territory of Florida,
and the ordinance that he published
says this, Ordinance Number 3,
an ordinance providing for the
naturalization of inhabitants
of the ceded territory by
Major General Andrew Jackson,
Governor of the Provinces of the
Floridas exercising the powers
of the Captain-General and the
Intendant of the Island of Cuba
over said Provinces
and the Governors
of said Provinces respectively.
Okay, so the idea here
is that simply by fiat,
Andrew Jackson made the
inhabitants of Florida citizens.
Now I spoke with, off the record
right, I spoke with a lawyer,
an immigration lawyer who said well
of course this is unconstitutional.
And so the question
immediately came up, right?
What about the citizenship
of all those Florida people,
which of course was taken care
of by the fourteenth
amendment, no problem.
They are all citizens, but certainly
for a few years after this,
it does raise a big question like
what was the meaning of this,
how much validity could it have
had, what was the legal background
that he was able to make
this proclamation, or not.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Dorn: Anyway, it's
a great little story.
>> Herrera: And we have it here.
>> Dorn: Yes, we do.
>> Herrera: And of course
this brings up so many things.
It kind of brings up the power of
laws, the role that laws played
and how they're made and how they
unfold through time as we notice
with Las Siete Partidas and
Spain and Mexico and New Orleans,
the unfolding of those laws
and adaptation and assimilation
of those laws and how words
and letters and writing,
how important they are,
how powerful they are,
and with illumination manuscripts
proving the honor of a noble person,
nobleman, and the aristocracy
and how these are available,
and in many ways in how we don't
really know they're available
in many cases and we have them
here at the Library of Congress...
>> Dorn: We sure do...
>> Herrera: ...in the
Law Library of Congress.
And what do you think would be good?
Let me see, I'm thinking out
loud with Nathan right now.
I want everybody, we want all of you
to think about these beautiful books
and you know they're ancient in
some ways, five hundred years.
That's a long time.
And they go back in time, the
Visigoths, Spain, and Mesoamerica,
and Mexico, and conquests,
and the rules of marriage,
the laws that govern our lives,
and citizenship, and books.
So, I want you to think about
all these things, about writing,
and indeed it is powerful.
And indeed, we create our
societies and follow our lives,
and in many ways, shape our
lives with these materials
and these voices, and these
studies, and these laws
and rules and marriage and family.
What are those things...how
to guide ourselves.
How to guide ourselves.
>> Dorn: That's what we do here.
>> Herrera: We were talking about
that, how to guide our lives.
And we do have rules
and yet there's room
for creativity and interpretation.
That's what it is.
>> Dorn: That's true.
>> Herrera: Yes, so let's
interpret and let's create.
Thanks so much, Nathan.
>> Dorn: It's a pleasure.
>> Herrera: Thank you so much.
I learned a lot.
>> Dorn: Me, too!
>> Herrera: I am going to
have to read these books.
>> Dorn: Good luck.
>> Herrera: Thanks a
lot, that was great.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.